you know I'm on the record saying that
we on the right should probably lay off
of Alexandria okay Joe Cortez a little
bit because this obsession with with
picking apart everything she says is
kind of bizarre and it seems almost like
conservatives have a bit of a crush on
her because they're they're just
constantly talking about her all the
time but I mean this this thing where
she doesn't know the branches of
government this is just oh this is just
bad this is this is bad and when I first
heard about this I thought well she must
have maybe she misspoke or I mean people
are making too much of this but then I
saw the video and it really let me I'm
sure you've seen this already but here's
what she said during a conference call
she said if we work our butts off to
make sure that we take back all three
chambers of Congress rather all three
chambers of government the presidency
the Senate and the house so what makes
this so bad
is that she said the wrong thing she
caught herself and then she corrected it
to something that's even more wrong so
we have to take back all three chambers
of Congress okay well that that's wrong
there are only two chambers not three
but there are chambers in Congress and
the Democrats want both of them so you
hear that you think well okay she just
misspoke but then she plunges forward
she keeps going and she says she says oh
no no the chambers of government Oh No
and then she lists them to Senate the
presidency in the house Oh
Alexandria Oh Alexandria that is not
that that is just there is nothing right
about that at all that's just wrong in
in in several different ways and the
problem is it she made it clear that she
read this is not her miss speaking she
really doesn't know she really just
simply does not know what the branches
of government are and she doesn't know
that they're called branches she thinks
they're called chambers so how does that
happen how do you get to the age of what
is she 28 22 age of 28 and you don't
know the branch of government how have
you gone through 12 years of schooling
and then and then college and you've
never encountered this information
before
and then you run for Congress and you
don't even know what Congress is or what
it does you can't possibly know what it
is or what it does if she doesn't know
that it's part of the legislative branch
oh goodness what a what if what a sad
statement what a sad statement all right
I want to kind of follow up I want to do
a part two on the show from yesterday if
you watch that show or you listen to it
you heard about the well it started with
the terrible tragic awful case of a nine
year old child who killed herself weeks
after starting a new ADHD drug and the
drug had suicidal thoughts as a listed
side effect now her parents say that she
was also bullied in school they think
that the drugs along with the bullying
were were factors in propelling her
towards this terrible tragedy
so we we started with that terrible case
and talked about psychiatric drugs and
ADHD in the fact that 7 million kids are
on psychiatric drugs is that really is
that a good thing is that a smart
strategy to put to put so many kids on
these drugs and why you look at the drug
companies and the doctors they seem to
exercise basically no caution whatsoever
and that's how we end up with millions
of kids on these drugs despite the side
effects
despite the long-term effects and
despite the lack of data the lack of
information that we actually have on on
on you know how these these drugs will
affect kids in the long term now here's
what happens anytime I talk about this
kind of subject about ADHD about the
dangers of psychiatric drugs for
children and so on I am going to be
informed by people who disagree with my
take that I can't possibly know what I'm
talking about
because my children don't have the
disorder I've never been through it I've
never experienced that so I need to shut
up because I don't know what it's like
now I'm not sure why or how people feel
comfortable making these kinds of
declarations about a stranger it's one
of the
weirdest things about the internet where
if you give an opinion invariably a
bunch of people are gonna say well you
don't know what you're talking about
you've never been through it you've
never experienced that you need to shut
up you don't know what how do you know
what I've experienced you know nothing
about my kids or about my life or or
anything how could you possibly know how
could anyone feel comfortable just
saying that well you've never you
clearly have never been through this
do you really just assume that everyone
with experience is similar to your own
must therefore have the same opinions as
you is that really how you think the
world works that nobody who's gone
through similar things as you could
possibly have arrived at different
conclusions that's that's really the
assumption underlying this is that
people think that well they've been
through this and anyone who's been
through it clearly must have come to the
same conclusions as them
it's it's such a narrow minded way of
looking at the world it's it's kind of
mind-boggling and anyway I'm not sure
what my personal experiences have to do
with anything
so this well you can't talk about that
topic unless you've been personally
affected by it argument is one of the
most cowardly forms of emotional
blackmail it's just a way of shutting
down discussion it's a way of a person
trying to win an argument by claiming
this emotional trump card the the
assumption that people who have been
personally affected by a certain thing
must therefore be more knowledgeable
about it and more credible when
discussing it is obviously ridiculous
just because you have car trouble
doesn't make you it doesn't make you a
mechanic right and if it did we wouldn't
need mechanics so just because you've
been through something doesn't mean that
your opinions about it whatever it is
are necessarily more true or more
grounded in facts than someone on the
outside the fact that you've been
through something does not make you an
expert and the fact that someone else
has not been through it doesn't mean
that they can't know anything about it
in fact your personal experiences could
hamper your judgement and could
make your insights could could kind of
compromise your judgment in a way
because because they they create an
obvious bias so yes if your kids are on
ADHD medication then hopefully you've
learned a thing or two about the
medication because your kids are on it
so you do have that knowledge but at the
same time you also have a clear
incentive to defend the medication no
matter what and to ignore the arguments
against it because you want to justify
the decision that you've already made so
I just don't think that this strategy
this this will my personal experience
Trump's your logical arguments thing
works I don't think it works in any case
in any situation now I'm not saying that
your personal experiences are worthless
I'm not saying that I think that they're
valuable to the conversation I think
they can add color they can add
perspective and so on but they don't
supersede facts and they don't supersede
logic and they don't give you an
exclusive right to have an opinion about
a subject okay that's my point
but as it happens I do have experience
oh I have are I've already shared
several times my own personal struggles
with getting through public school as a
kid with with this disorder
I was never diagnosed with the with the
disorder officially because that was not
a direction that my parents were going
to go they were not looking to
medicalize my academic problems but I am
familiar with ADHD I have read the
descriptions I know what the symptoms
are and I see myself in pretty much
every symptom described then and now I
have a lot of trouble focusing I can't
keep my mind going on one track for very
long if you listen to this podcast
you've probably already noticed that
because I'll branch off in a million
directions and depart from the point
that I was making and in-circle back
though that's just how my my mind works
I can't sit still
I have trouble going to bed at night
because I can't turn my mind off on and
on and on
ii-i've been there IIM there so I dunno
and so you can't like hold it against me
that I've never gotten official
diagnosis I am opposed to the diagnosis
that's why I am NOT going to go and seek
one out because of my own personal
opinion about this whole this
whole thing I've also been through it as
a parent I'm going through it right now
so I have two emotional trump cards I
guess that means I win right I guess
that means when my according to the
rules according to the rules of modern
debate I win because I've got two trump
cards my five-year-old son fits the ADHD
label by any measure as many
five-year-old boys do and that's the
point but what I can tell you about my
five-year-old son is that is that to
just call him energetic would be a huge
understatement I mentioned this on the
show yesterday but I want a lab right
here
my son is imagine imagine a squirrel
that got into a can of coffee beans and
ate all the coffee beans okay that's
that's my that's my son he runs through
the house at a million miles an hour
he's running around he's fighting off
imaginary pirates and dragons he pull
volts over banisters and jumps over
couches and literally bounces off the
walls he climbs everything he swings on
anything that is remotely swing a bull
the the the kid he cannot sit still he
cannot stop talking he won't even stop
taut you can't stop him from talking by
leaving the room because he'll continue
the conversation even if you're not
there he reminds me a lot of Macaulay
Culkin at home alone just kind of
walking around the house narrating
himself narrating what he's doing that's
what he does and he does have trouble
learning in a formal setting is his um
he he does struggle to learn
academically now he's only five years
old but but he does have that problem
and we do have a comparison here because
he has a twin sister and his twin sister
is significantly more advanced when it
comes to the ABCs and one two threes and
spelling and all that kind of stuff
she's and she is also and I think this
is the reason why she's more advanced
he's there's she can sit still for for
several minutes at a time she can sit
she'll color she'll she'll draw pictures
she'll look at a book
she'll brush her dolls hair so she can
do that she
she likes to clean for some reason if
you can believe it Scheck she likes to
clean and she's better at it than I am
like she'll fold laundry and she'll make
her bed make it all nice and nice and
pretty and neat and and she does it
better than it looks better at the end
than it would have looked if I had done
it she had she pays attention pretty
well she remembers things she remembers
where things are she you know her mind
is organized in that way it this this is
how bad it is when her mom is not around
and and I'm looking for something around
that because I'm totally a stereotypical
husband who can't find anything in the
house I'm always asking my wife where it
is but the problem is if if I'm looking
for something and my wife isn't there
and of course the first thing I do is I
text my wife
but if she doesn't answer then what am I
gonna do so I asked my five-year-old
daughter where the thing is and I do
that all the time and she'll she'll find
it for me now
she's no angel believe me I'm not she
she can be a challenge in her own way
unfortunately her brother inherited my
ADHD her and she inherited my
stubbornness so we've got both of that
going on but she doesn't have she's not
the same as as her brother and that's
not unusual because boys are much more
likely to have ADHD than girls which is
a fact that people who believe in ADHD
as a medical diagnosis they never really
grapple with this fact why is it have
you ever thought about why is it more
common in boys isn't that a weird
coincidence that boys just so happened
to be more rambunctious and energetic
and more likely to run around and all
that kind of and they also are more
likely to be diagnosed with ADHD isn't
that a weird have you ever stopped to
think about that does that not doesn't
that shake your faith in ADHD as a
medical diagnosis a little bit that it
just so happens to be so much more
common in the types of people who are
predisposed anyway to to to be energetic
and less focused now so that's my
I you know my son unlike his sister
can't find anything he probably couldn't
find his own feet if I asked him to he
loses everything which is bad because
he's also in the habit of taking off his
shoes as soon as he enters into a
building of any kind he's gonna have his
shoes off with it within about 2 and 1/2
seconds the shoes are off and they're
also lost so he lose his stuff all the
time
he doesn't like anything that involves
sitting and drawing or writing or
counting he cleans by picking up all the
items that were on the floor throwing
them into a pile on the nearest piece of
furniture and then sometimes I'll even
jump into the pile like it's a pile of
leaves yeah out in the yard or something
the point is he could easily earn the
label ADHD if we went if we sought out
that diagnosis I have no doubt in my
mind whatsoever that my son could could
get that diagnosis but we're not going
to seek that diagnosis because the boy
is not sick he's not disordered the boy
is just a boy he's more of a handful
than some boys he's less of a handful
than other boys he has his own
personality and I cannot imagine
treating it like the manifestation of a
mental disease besides like like almost
every kid with an actual ADHD diagnosis
he can learn he can focus he just
doesn't always learn the things we want
him to learn in the ways we want him to
learn them so he can't remember how to
spell simple words but he remembers
songs he sings all the time he's
constantly singing he'll wake up the
whole house at 6:00 a.m. singing to
himself as loudly as he can sometimes he
makes up songs on the spot he freestyles
sometimes he were its songs that he
heard at church or on the radio so he
remembers that he knows his superheroes
backwards and forwards he can name all
the superheroes for you that might not
be useful information but it is it is it
is information anyway that he's
remembered he he knows other he knows
about Pilgrims and Indians because
that's a story that really fascinates
him right now and he's
so he's fixated on that he knows about
ants and bugs and just yesterday he
randomly started telling me all these
facts about George Washington and he was
he was recalling details from our family
trip to a Mount Vernon last year we went
a year ago and randomly he's talking
about this trip and what he remembered
about George Washington he was the first
president and so on so we took the kids
to see some old warships at the Harbor
last week and he remembers the ships and
he's always talked about ship he wants
to go back and take a more extensive
tour of the ships so if if my son was in
public school I have no doubt that they
would probably tell us he has a learning
disability but he he doesn't he learns
all the time he loves to learn he's just
he just he just likes to learn in his
own way and about topics that interest
him and he likes to learn in a way
that's more hands-on but the fact that
he can that he is fascinated likes to
learn about topics that interest him and
he doesn't like learning about topics
that don't interest him well what's is
that is that really is that really the
symptom of a disability I'm the same way
I think I think most people are now yes
you do you have to be able to even if
he's not interested in math and spell he
still is gonna have to learn the basics
there at some point but the problem is
we we look at these boys and we said
well they can't learn anything they
can't pay attention they can't they
can't they can't focus well in almost
every case that's not true they can
focus on some things just not the things
we might want and yeah that can be a
challenge and it the fact that he's so
rambunctious can also be a challenge it
does wear you down sometimes I shared
the story on Facebook a couple days ago
shared again here a couple nights ago I
was you know I've had this on my mind
because a couple of nights ago I was you
know maybe an hour before the kids were
supposed to go to bed and I was feeling
especially not in the mood for his
antics that that night I just was kind
of in a bad mood I was annoyed I
it's put off I just wanted peace and
quiet but my son is running around and
doing his whole thing and so I told him
very sternly to calm down and be quiet
and and then I had to stop and I
realized that I was I was being selfish
you know there wasn't anything wrong
with how he was acting I just didn't
feel like dealing with it right and I
think so often
that's why boys are drugged and punished
and scolded in our society because we
just don't feel like dealing with them
they present challenges that we lack the
patience to meet especially in a school
setting and I'm as guilty of this
attitude as anyone even as a even as a
man myself I was I was a young boy once
I was a boy just like him but I can very
easily lapse into this thing where it's
like I don't even remember what it was
like to be a five year old boy and I
expect him to not act like a five year
old boy I want him to act like I want to
act like a like a like a world-weary 32
year old man sometimes just because I
don't feel like listening to it but I
caught myself on this particular night
and I realized how ridiculous that is
and I realized that I was angry at my
son for the crime of being happy and
exuberant how absurd is that why should
that annoy me he's maybe he's maybe he's
got the right idea
maybe we should all be running around
the house why not it's better than
sitting on the couch sulking like I was
doing so so that's what I did I got up
and you know if you can't beat them join
them sometimes as a parent so I ran
around the house with them and we
wrestled we had a pillow fight we did
piggyback rides
we played his favorite game which
involves him standing on the coffee
table and then jumping onto my chest
nearly cracking my ribs and puncturing
my lungs in the process and then we got
to other kids so that and his younger
brother and his sister they also wanted
to join in so they were taking turns
just jumping up pile driving me
basically and I barely survived but they
had fun and they went to bed tired
they actually fell asleep relatively
quickly at least by their standards now
obviously we need to teach our boys to
be obedient and respectful and they
really do need to calm down and be quiet
sometimes but little boys also need to
be little boys they they need to be able
to run around and be crazy and make
noise and be rambunctious that's an
actual physical need that they have it's
it's not just it would be nice if they
could act that way they need to act that
way they need that and I'm afraid that
they are rarely given that opportunity
these days especially if you I mean the
very idea that we take five six seven
year old boys and we put them down in a
classroom and we say you need to spend
the next seven hours doing busywork and
then when they struggle mightily to
perform that task we drug them I mean
just think about that just stop and
think about what we're doing whoever
said that a seven-year-old boy is
supposed to be able to do that did we
ever stop to think that boy that a kid
like that just isn't supposed to be
doing that no I know it well but if he
doesn't do that we need him to do that
because he needs to learn this very
quickly so we can go to college and you
can get a job at at 9:00 to 5:00 and
it's a cubicle and you know have a but
you know we have his whole life planned
out for him we've got his life planned
out for him we we know what the schedule
needs to be so you've got to learn this
now then learn that then learn that then
do that and we've got it all mapped out
do we ever stop to think that our map is
wrong do we ever stop to think that our
map is self-serving that this is what we
want our kids to do and how we want them
to act
little boys are always being told no
stop calm down be quiet sit still we
treat boyhood like like something that
needs to be medicated or fixed like this
malignant growth that we have to extract
and discard we have literally made
boyhood into a mental illness and why
because we need them to fit into the
systems that we have in place we need
them to go with the flow at our pace on
our schedule I think we are ruining our
sons I think we are robbing them of so
much of themselves III think that we are
the ones who need to change if there is
no room in our schools in our homes in
our culture for boys who act like boys
then our schools and our homes and our
culture not our boys are sick there is a
balance I'm not saying there is we can't
let them always do what they want we do
have to teach them the guidelines and
the rules and how to follow them but I
also think that sometimes rather than
making them fit in with us and go at our
pace maybe we should try to fit in with
them and go at their pace and then
they'll burn off a little energy that
way and also you know everybody has a
little bit of fun I think we could learn
you know we could learn from our from
our sons how to have some fun in life at
the very least I just think it's some
and that's why I just find it so
unconvincing from my own experience from
what I've read from everything and then
now with my own son when somebody tells
me look my eight-year-old boy you don't
understand he just can't sit still at
the desk he can't he just can't do it
yeah I know he can't maybe he's not
supposed to be doing that maybe that is
a completely unnatural and ridiculous
thing to require a young boy to do maybe
he would learn better hands on
maybe he would learn better going out on
field trips and and and seeing things
and you know actually pouring it's like
my son if I tried to sit down and say
son let me read you some facts about old
battleships from from you know from from
a hundred years ago it wouldn't work but
I take him to the harbor look at the
ships we take a tour we do all that and
he learns that he remembers if I tried
to sit him down and just give him a
bunch of facts about George Washington
and then tell him to write down those
facts and repeat them to me it's not
gonna work
I take him to Mount Vernon we go on a
tour we see the house we do all that and
he learns and he remembers now I know
that we can't we can't always teach our
kids that way so I realize that but
we've gone way in the other direction
and we try their entire educational
experience almost involves them sitting
at a desk being told information and
then having to repeat it and my point is
there are some people who just don't
operate that way
unless you drugged them but that's the
wrong approach because the fact that
they don't operate that way isn't wrong
it's not disordered that's just how they
are
and that's okay all right um let's see
where we are I briefly wanted to mention
one other thing there was a video that
went viral on do I want to do this today
yeah I'll just mention now a video went
viral on Friday showing a Chipotle
employee a woman telling a group of
customers black men that they had to
prove that they had money before she
started preparing the food for them and
and they cried racism and and the video
went on went up on Twitter and everyone
on the internet cried racism and the
employee was was was fired almost
immediately and then a couple of days
later it turns out that these guys most
likely stole food food from that very
restaurant earlier
in the week and they had previously
posted on Twitter openly bragging about
dining and dashing that is Lee leaving
without paying for the food so these
guys they were literally on the internet
bragging about about stealing food and
so that's why the Chipotle employee
wouldn't make them food because they're
thieves and she recognized them as
thieves because they'd stolen from that
very store and they've admitted to being
thieves now so the video comes out out
of context everyone assumes she's racist
it goes viral she loses her job her face
and her name's out there for everybody
to see and then a couple of days later
we get the update of oh well these guys
are just thieves and that's why she
didn't want to give him food now I
didn't see the video or hear about it
until until yesterday but if I had seen
her on Friday I would have said the same
thing that I've said in similar
situations which is it is insane to jump
to the conclusion that the girl is
racist I mean to all the people who call
her racist who called a racist right
away demanded that she be fired based on
the video they saw on the internet I
have this question what did you think
did you think this person had never
served a black person before do you
think or did you think that she had some
kind of policy for all black people
where they all had to show their money
ahead of time because they're black and
that somehow were just now hearing about
it and somehow she was never fired for
it before no obviously that doesn't make
sense obviously if you see this
interaction and then you think oh she's
just doing that because they're black
then your first question as a commons as
a logical person should be well wait a
minute if she's just doing that because
they're black I mean she's presumably
served hundreds of other black people
and apparently she's never done this
before so what did she just suddenly
become racist overnight did did she wake
up racist she woke up as a KKK
slobbering drooling crazy
racist all of a sudden did she does she
fall and hit her head and become racist
or does she have a specific issue with
these specific people for a specific
reason a common sense should tell you
that there's probably more to the story
soap all the people who saw this video
and said she's racist I can only come to
one of two conclusions about them either
they are incredibly stupid that they
never made this common-sense calculation
that any intelligent and rational person
would make or they are liars and they
knew that there's probably more to the
story they knew that that it's very
likely that there's a good reason why
these guys were treated this way yet
they decided to call a racist and put
her name out there and put her face out
there take her job away from her I mean
honestly put her life in jeopardy when
you put someone's face in their name out
for the entire world to see and you say
this person is a racist you have put
their life in jeopardy because you don't
know somebody recognizes them in public
and loses their temper you know you
don't know what's gonna happen so it's
either that all the people that jumped
on the outrageous bandwagon there are
they're a bunch of idiots or they knew
what they were doing and they were
willing to destroy this innocent woman's
life for no reason just because and
honestly I don't know what's worse I
mean do I want to believe that that that
the society is really filled with people
who are that incredibly stupid or with
people who are that evil it's kind of
like those are the two options when you
see something like this and you jump to
conclusions when there are very clearly
other logical explanations that could
explain what happened it's I mean it's
it's either you're just a bad person or
you're really stupid III don't know is
there a third option I don't think there
is
and I'm just so tired of this and I'm so
tired of people not this is someone's
life we're talking about this woman
who's been unfairly slandered it's her
life this is our livelihood this is this
is this is it a human being what is
wrong with you people
doing this to it what did she do to you
and for all you know she could be I
don't know anything about it she could
be on your side with all this maybe for
all we know she's a she's a liberal /
she's she's on you she's won it she's on
your team and you just rip her apart for
no reason you know we like to think that
we have we have kind of graduated beyond
the days of the the days of the
Colosseum in Rome when innocent people
would be fed to the Lions while all the
spectators cheered but we have not
really graduated from that at all we've
just we've just taken that philosophy
and we have put it online and we do the
cyber version of it it's a very sad
statement all right we'll leave it there
thanks for watching thanks for listening
Godspeed